This is Jocko podcast number
30 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
And what we have this
evening is straight Q and a.
The last podcast that we did on the
outstanding book called Platoon leader,
a memoir of combat of command in combat.
It just took me a long time to
get through it. Just a good book.
And I just kept every s word,
you know, like every time,
every page I read it.
So you've got people got here
that and people got to hear that.
People got to hear that.
And then the next thing you know,
you're two and a half hours deep.
And since so much of what
was pertained to leadership,
there was commentary with each section
and it was like, oh yeah, you know,
this is what's going on here.
And I recognize that and I wish I would've
known that and know that could have
helped me here. So, uh,
went a little long and that made us
decide to just go ahead and turn that into
one podcast.
And now here we are coming back
at you with podcast number 30,
which is straight Q and a.
Yeah.
There wasn't really one part of that
book review that I was like, oh,
you could have left that out. No. In
the industry we call that getting after.
Indeed. So let's, uh, let's
take into some Q and a here.
Some questions that we've been asked.
You're going to kick this one off.
Yes sir. Eggo journals. Yes sir.
Question number one. First question.
Ductile as an aide to camp,
what were your duties?
What did you learn and why does that
position still exist in the 21st century
military? Well, the aid to
count. Okay. So first of all,
in aid to camp is something
in the military that
it's almost, I mean to, to,
to put it in a very simple way that
people could understand it from,
it's an assistant.
It's like an executive assistant.
Where for me,
I was,
I was the admiral that's
in charge of all the seals.
I was his assistant. You know,
that's when an aid to campus. Now
the question is why does that position
still exist? Or what do you know?
What did you learn while I learned a ton,
no doubt about that.
Why does the position still exist? I think
it's absolutely necessary. It's a good,
it's a, it's not fun. It's not a
fun job. And I work for a great guy,
but it's, but if you're working for
somebody that's not a great guy,
it's miserable. And even working for a
great guy, it's not exactly the dream job.
It wasn't for me. So here's
what you do. The, the boss,
which is what we call, this is what we
called the Aba. We called them the boss.
Right? Um, so what we did was,
what I did was the boss is always
traveling and going different places,
going to the Pentagon, going to
visit, outstations, going overseas,
going just constantly going on travel
and visiting people and visiting troops.
And so I was the guy that
set up that travel. That's,
that's what I did. I set up
the travel and then, you know,
communicating with wherever you're going
to visit my k, the admiral's coming in,
you know, what do you want us to do? Is
there anything we need to be heads up on?
So we'd take care of all that and set
it up and make sure that the travel
smooth, cause he's a really busy
guy. It's like a CEO, you know,
he's like the CEO of a big giant,
powerful worldwide company.
That's where he is. And so you're
trying to make the most of his time,
make sure we're not wasting his time
during travel. And so that's what I did.
So that's,
that's part of it.
And then the other piece
that's cool is your,
you're kind of like a,
a trusted advisor or you try and
build the trust so that he trusts you.
And they usually,
in our case usually often tried to find
guys that had come back from the front
lines and use them as the,
the aide.
And so I had, when I became the aide,
who was actually my commanding officer,
he, uh, who's, who's,
who's a friend of mine and who's a
great guy that always took care of me.
And he told me, he said, hey, my,
my final mission as the commanding
officer of seal team seven is to make sure
that you become the aid to the admiral.
And you know, I wasn't happy about it.
Cause again, you're, it's, it's an,
it's an administrative job. It's, you have
to wear a uniform every day, which was
2005.
And um,
but it was,
it was a good call that the debt,
my commanding officer made me go do it
because I did learn a ton. You know, you,
you,
I had been in,
in the micro world of being a seal
platoon for my whole life. Right.
So that's all I did. And so yeah,
I didn't know anything else.
I didn't understand anything else. So
when you go, all of a sudden you're,
you're dealing with not only do you see
the big picture of the seal teams is
what I saw the big picture of the army
in the Special Operations Command and big
navy, like the regular navy.
We interacted with them a lot.
So I got to learn a ton.
I learned a ton about what I learned.
It's sorta like seeing behind the curtain,
you know,
you get to see behind the curtain,
the wizard and the what's going on in
the chambers. And basically, you know,
like how they make the sausage,
you reverbed that term, you know,
they say when they make sausage, like
you'll eat the sausage, it tastes good,
but you don't want to see
how they make it. So that's,
I got to see how they make the sausage.
I got to see behind the curtain
and I learned a ton of that.
You know,
I got to sit and like there was meetings
that I would sit in super high level
meetings with very powerful people in
the meetings and I would just be sitting
in there listening and seeing how these
judgments were being made and assessing
the leadership and seeing what type of
leaders we had at the highest levels of
the Pentagon.
And as those pretty,
it was pretty interesting and
I definitely learned a lot. Um,
it, it was not fun because like I
said, there was a ton of travel.
You're wearing a uniform all the time,
which seals are pretty well known
for not wanting to wear uniforms,
real uniforms.
And there I'd probably worn a uniform,
a very small number of times.
I'm talking to my whole naval career,
a dress uniform.
I'd probably worn one 15 times.
I,
I don't know the number,
but it's a tiny number and all of a
sudden I'm at the working for the admiral.
I'm wearing a uniform every single day.
And there were some times we'd go on
a trip and I'd have to where there's
multiple different dress
uniforms in the navy.
And then most of the services we'd go
on some where I'd have to bring two or
three different dress uniforms. So my
uniforms, we're always ready. That was,
that was one thing that not too many
people could claim as you get really good
at your uniforms. Um, but there's,
there's also some things that are
pretty restrictive. Like for instance,
you're actually not allowed to
do personal favors for the boss.
Like I wasn't allowed because this idea,
the milk,
because they're very cautious that the
military senior people might abused
people in the military. Oh
yeah. And like I wasn't allowed,
for instance, I wasn't allowed
to go pick up his laundry.
Like if he got,
if he got his uniform's pressed and clean,
I wasn't allowed to go and run
to the store and pick it up.
If we were going on a trip
or something like you will,
it wasn't allowed to do it.
We weren't allowed to fly First Class III.
The w there was only one time
we flew first class. That was,
we'd get upgrades after awhile because
we were traveling so much. But um,
so both of you guys couldn't or just
the just the, the aide to camp? No,
neither one of us. We wouldn't
fly first class. Yeah, it's,
it's the military sort of,
you know, we don't want that. They don't
want there to be fraud, waste and abuse,
which is actually ridiculous.
This guy is the equivalent of a CEO
of a big company and they don't,
they wouldn't get the guy first class
tickets to fly from San Diego to
Washington DC to go to the Pentagon
and brief some senior governmental
leadership fully. That's a good
philosophy though. No way thing. Yeah,
I know it's a good philosophy,
but uh, they should have,
I think he learned at that
point 30 something years
in the navy for that server
in his country and just to be,
you know, hey, you know what?
This guy should be well rested when he
shows up to brief congress, you know.
So, um, that was that.
And then the reason I think it's again
is because you got, you take a guy,
the old, the, the admiral there,
they're not going to usually or often
may not have been in recent combat
situations.
And so there's aid that's coming in.
He's coming off the battlefield so he
can say, Hey, saw hers is going on here.
Hey Sir, this is what
this is like, Hey sir,
this is some gear that we need
up on the front lines. Hey Sir,
this is what the front line troopers
think about this program that we're doing
or this a rule that's
being imposed upon us.
We need to change this or
we need to get it fixed.
So I had a great relationship with,
with,
with a boss when I was
running that job and,
and it was very beneficial for me on my
next appointment when I deployed Ramadi
and I knew the admiral.
I mean it was, you know,
he's the guy that's in charge of all
seals and there I was in Ramadi and you
know, there was times where we
talk directly, you know, uh,
he called me up and say, Hey,
what's going on? Or, you know,
after my guys got killed he called
me up directly and, and that,
that really meant a lot to me.
And I think it meant a lot to him too
because he had a connection with the guys
that were out there cause he knew
me and knew, you know, knew me well.
So I think that was, I think I was
very important and I think it's a,
it's a good job. I'm not going
to say you're going to like it.
If there's troopers out there
that are up for that job,
you're not going to like it if you're,
if you're a hardcore getting
after it kind of guy,
you're not going to like the job.
The people that actually in the scary
thing is the people that volunteer and
want to have that job are usually the
guys the animals don't want because that's
a guy that's like focused on
advancing his career and hey,
if I'm can be an aide then I'll know
the admiral and then and so you're not
going to, those are the
guys, the animals actually,
at least the avenue I worked for,
he didn't want any guys like that.
He wanted guys over and say,
Oh,
I want a guy that's going to come
kicking and screaming to this job
because he doesn't want to wear a uniform.
He wants to be in the field.
I want to be in the field. So that's,
that's kind of a, the aide to camp.
So if there's a trooper out there
that's it's going to get pushed in that
position. You know, you
might have to do it. And
when you do it, you do the best that you
can win. The guy that took over for me,
he said, cause I was, you know, I was,
I've always been early to work or
when I was working for the boss,
I wasn't even earlier because this
is, you know, I've, I've felt this,
this responsibility that, you know,
I got to take care of this guy.
He's taking care of all the seals. I got
to take care of him, right? This guy,
the more, the easier I make his job
to make it easier to make his life,
the more he can focus on taking care of
all the guys that are in the field and
all the seals.
And so when I,
I was getting show up even earlier
than I would normally show up and I was
double and triple and quadruple check
everything that was going on. And,
and when the guy came in to relieve
me and take my place and he said,
he said, you know, hey, how does the,
how does the boss react if you
dropped the ball on something?
And I said, I don't know. I don't know.
I didn't drop the ball. I mean
that's, that was, you know,
a lot of luck involved and I had some,
some other guys that were with me that
really helped me out. Uh, you know,
one guy in particular as a
civilian guy that is steady works,
has always worked there and worked
there for a long time and he was always
covering my tracks and help me not drop
the ball but I never dropped the ball.
It's kind of a good answer though,
cause that question because you know,
if you were like, Oh hey, well
he doesn't take it so hard.
Almost like that might plant something
in his mind where it may not be as
important every single time or
something like that. That's important.
Every time you can't drop the ball.
Got to keep it going.
Is it ever viewed by people,
whatever that, that job.
So like kind of emasculating or
something cause you're like, like,
like an assistant more so than
the, you know, I dunno. Maybe,
maybe somebody you've used it that way.
You know,
I want military guy that got tasks where
the job to take care of the senior seal
officer and keep his day moving so
that he can take care of the troops.
I don't, I think that's
beneficial, like, right. I, I
didn't, I didn't feel that way.
And the other thing is you're not,
like I said,
you're not allowed to do certain things.
You're not allowed to do
personal things for him.
And even,
and the guy that I worked for
was very laid back and, uh,
I mean,
and part of the reason he was laid back
was because I'd never dropped the ball
form. I wouldn't want to drop the ball
because I'm sure he would be angry. Um,
but yeah, it wasn't new.
It wasn't a bad job. Yeah.
I would think if you understand
the value of the job,
really understand the
value of a job, um, you,
you probably will never really feel
emasculated or anything. No. But I think,
you know, sometimes some of us
can go into jobs and be like,
you know, I'm a, I'm a leader.
I'm not a helper. You know,
kind of kind of attitude.
Yeah.
Well it's interesting too because when
you're working for the admiral then when
you speak,
you kind of kind of,
you kind of speak for the admiral.
So in other words,
when I'd go in to talk to some
senior captains and I said, hey,
can I get a copy of Xyz? Right. They
knew it wasn't me that wanted it.
They knew it was the boss at wanted it.
So people are snapping too.
So it was pretty, it was interesting
from that perspective. You know,
all I was a young lieutenant at the time,
I'd go in and say, hey can we get this?
We need this report.
And the guys would be like jumping to
like full captains would be jumping too.
Cause they knew that it wasn't for me
and they respected the boss and they
wanted to help him out.
So it was you, do you,
you get a little bit of added
weight because people know,
especially because people kind of knew
we had a good relationship and so they
knew that if I was asking for something
or I needed something or I was
suggesting something,
they knew where it was coming from.
They knew it was coming
from the big boss man.
So it kind of like like the executive
assistant to like Oprah or something.
Well,
no,
there you go.
We're not going to talk about the verse
and that you just talked about on this
podcast is not happening.
Gotcha.
Error Error.
I'm just saying,
you know, if he'd go around
and you're like, Hey, I need,
I would say it would be the equivalent
of being the executive assistant to a
very powerful CEO that has a lot of,
that has a lot of stress and decisions
to make and has a large global
corporation. Yeah. In there
under their command actually in.
That kind of reminds me of the
whole flying first class thing.
And I thought about this where there was
a big part of me that thought, Oh yeah,
a lot of guys they'll just fly first class
just cause that's like a status thing
and like, Oh yeah, I'm this high. So
I get to kind of live in this luxury.
But flying first class eliminates
a lot of stress and a lot of um,
like decision making and headaches,
you know,
we're contending with certain things.
So when you arrive you have way less
on your mind. So, and that, that,
that's a lot you ever had.
You ever had to do something or
convey something important message,
but you have a lot on your mind
to some other stuff. It's a,
it makes it way harder than I just
prioritize and execute. No, right. I know,
but every day it has its function.
That's what I'm saying. It does. It does.
And there was the time that the literally
the one time we were authorized and
executed a first class travel was
when we flew to Europe and the,
when we arrived at six
o'clock in the morning,
the boss or seven o'clock in the morning,
the boss was talking to the troops a
half an hour later and then the whole day
was scheduled out talking to
the local senior leadership.
So he needed to be arrested
when he showed up there. Yeah.
Now me on the other hand, if I remember
correctly, I was in the cheap seats,
but you don't really need that much for
us as a young lieutenant can just suck
it up cause it was pretty pathetic.
We're sitting here talking about
FirstClass do we? Oh, you know what?
Let's just talk about Bob Hoffman. Do
you know what I mean? World War One.
Trench warfare. Yeah. He don't think he
used to worried about flying first class.
We had a lot of decisions to me. Yeah.
So let's just suck it up. Suck it up.
All right. That's a question Jocko. Do
you have a suggestion for a martial art?
For a wheelchair user?
I'm considering FMA,
Filipino martial arts or Krav Maga.
I want exercise and self defense.
Well again,
this is as usual,
my first suggestion for true self defense,
to protect yourself from the
world and the evils of the world.
Concealed carry,
you know, get a weapon, learn how to shoot
a weapon, spend time at the range, train,
train with it is a more shooting a weapon
as a martial art carrying a weapon as
a martial art,
knowing how to use that weapon in
various situations. It is a martial art.
So shooting is a martial art and so
that's the most effective martial art to
know and to have the possession of is
concealed carry carry
weapons. So the, again,
I'm not saying that just because
this individuals in a wheelchair,
because I mean obviously being in a
wheelchair does put you at a disadvantage,
but it doesn't matter.
Wheelchair or not.
There's always going to be somebody
that's bigger and badder than you.
And if there's not somebody
that's bigger and badder than you,
then there's three or four people combined
together that make a person that's
better than you. That's called a
game. And I will tell you right now,
any three people in the world can beat
anyone in the world in a fight like three
on one, you're going to lose. Oh,
now can you get a guy that put knock
somebody that somebody out turns around?
Lack of,
I mean it does happen,
but if the people that are attacking no
anything view have a really bad chance,
really bad chance of winning. It's
very tough to win a fight three on one.
So trained with firearms, get
a gun. And you know, also,
and you mentioned the Filipino
martial arts and, and I,
I sometimes fail to mention this,
uh, to carry a knife. But yeah,
you should absolutely have a knife.
You should know how to use it.
So that is your Filipino martial arts
generally learning to use a knife and
carry a knife. And then what do I,
what am I going to do after that?
I'm going to do the same thing. I
always talk about Jujitsu, boxing,
wrestling in boy tie, kind of in
that order. Now do Jitsu. Boxing,
wrestling, Moy, Tai, we started
with Jujitsu. We move on to boxing.
We learn wrestling and learn more
tie. Sometimes Moy, Tai and resting.
You can flip back and forth which one
you want to focus on, but, but the,
the deal is with all three of those,
you have to adapt them to
the situation that you're in.
Whatever that situation is.
Now, if you're in a wheelchair,
I don't know what this is
going to look like for you.
I don't know what that looks like.
You got to learn it.
You've got to understand it. You've got,
and then you've got to make things work.
You've got to figure it out.
You've got to test it.
You've got to see what's effective and
you've got to see what isn't effective.
And you have to adapt. You have
to adapt. And I've trained with
all kinds of different people that
have their own obstacles to overcome.
Um,
I've trained with guys that have
amputees missing one leg, two legs,
missing arms.
I've trained with people that are blind.
I've trained with people that are,
I've trained with people
with traumatic brain injuries
and they all work and
try and figure it away.
And they do figure ways to adapt. I mean,
you got guys like, uh, Kyle Maynard,
do you know who that is?
He's got no arms and no legs and he
trains Jiu Jitsu and he wrestled and he
wrestled in high school. Like he competed
and he, he's competed in Jujitsu.
He's actually competed in the MMA
as well, which is, which is crazy.
Uh, but you know what, he adapts
to the situation that he's in.
Um, man, there's um, Anthony Robles,
he's a NC Day Ncaa hundred and
25 pound champion champion.
And by the way, he has
one leg. I mean, one leg,
his other leg has gone like from the
hip down one leg and he won the Ncaa
Championship. That's incredible. Um,
and he just adapted when you guys,
Jacques Machado, he's got one
hand, Jeffrey Al Jeffrey, al.
He's trains with us. He's got
one hand, his other hand's gone.
He was born with no hand. Oh, guess what?
Now all all you Jujitsu players out there
that you think about when you're doing
Jujitsu with the ghee and think of how
much you grab when you're trading with
Jeff. You don't even know that he doesn't
have a hand. You just don't even know.
He just does other stuff. He's
adapted to it. As a matter of fact,
he uses that stump to choke you and attack
you. It gets in there. Yeah, he, he,
he sneaks that thing in there.
Um,
what about Max Maximilian?
Yeah. Yeah. Max Wright. Max.
He's, if he's paralyzed,
but, and that's recent too.
So he got paralyzed. What, three years?
Five, four years ago, five years ago,
something like that. He was like
maybe a white belt, maybe a blue belt.
He's a blue belt, I think is performed
now. Yeah, I think he's a purple now.
But I mean, he's got basically,
I think it's about sternum down.
He's completely paralyzed,
sternum down. And he,
so he's figured out he actually
has to move his legs. You know,
like when he's,
when you're rolling with him,
he's got to grab his legs and move them
into different positions, which is, uh,
which is crazy,
but he's still training.
He's advancing in his and
he's learning to adapt.
He though he knows how to choke
you. He, he's figured things out.
So whether you're short or tall,
big or small, older, young, stronger
week, wheelchair, no wheelchair,
leg, no leg, learn it,
learn it all and start with
you did to learn some maxing,
some boy tie than wrestling.
And then once you get that base built up,
start looking at Krav Maga.
I started looking at Cali
so you can learn, you know,
if you want to learn weapons and
obviously from the beginning, um,
that the firearm trumps everything.
Yeah.
Yeah. Especially when
you're training with, um,
like any kind of disadvantage or whatever.
I think it's important to understand what
your potential goal will be in a self
defense situation. So if you're, you know,
like if you don't have
legs like Max for example,
like you can learn a lot of
stuff that is just defensive.
And if you know Jujitsu, and I sound
like a Jujitsu advocate, which I am,
but if you learn Jujitsu,
you'll learn how to be defensive,
how you can shut down another guy's
attacks. And he's so like I said,
like if your adventure,
like you're disadvantaged is pretty big,
just understand what your goals will be
in a potential self defense situation.
You know? So you're not
going to be like, okay,
I'm going to learn these martial arts
so I can kick as much as I possibly can.
That's the point. The point of
this is that you have to adapt.
You have to adapt. You have to say, okay,
this is one of maybe what we'll do
and this is, I can't do that move,
but I can do this move. Right. And by the
way, you can't do this, but I can do that.
Yes. And you don't like, like we were
just talking about Jeffrey Jeffrey.
I was a guy trained with most regularly
out of the out of these folks and he has
adapted and does things that you,
that is totally unique to
him and he makes it an event.
He takes a disadvantage, turns it
into an advantage, you know? Yeah.
There's an MMA guy who, who was the champ
and one of these shows I for, I forget,
it might've been Bella tour maybe,
I don't know. I forget, but he, uh,
he had one hand too, and he was
the champ though. And I think one,
how do I not know who that is? I
forget his name too, but it was while,
it was like maybe a year ago or
something or more a while ago,
a year and [inaudible] has been around
for 20 plus years in America. You know,
the current champ is always
seems so new. Yeah. That's, uh,
that's awesome. That's, that
is definitely a outstanding,
to see people overcome that and
in what you can do.
You just got to have that, that, that
the creative mind to get in there
and adapt to the situation. Yeah.
And it goes along with kind of
what I think it was. I forget who,
but um, how they say, you know, a little
exercise is better than no exercise,
you know?
So sometimes like if you,
if you find yourself in a wheelchair or
something like this, where he'll be like,
oh yeah, that's not for me. But
this obviously is for him, you know?
So get out there and like, are you saying
like learn something or learn it all,
whatever. That's better than not
knowing nothing. Yep. Way Better too.
Especially if it's
good.
Get after it. That's it.
Next question. Jocko.
Mr Jocko,
whenever I get mentally overwhelmed,
I shut down completely.
How do I counter that?
Well, the first thing and the first good
step that you've already made as you've
identified this as an issue,
you recognize the fact that you shut down.
That's step number one in solving your
problem is identifying your problem.
So excellent work there. The next
step is actually pretty easy as well.
You've identified the
fact that you shut down.
The next step that you're going to do is
not shut down, not mentally shut down.
That's what you want to do.
If you start to shut down and you
feel yourself freezing up and say,
I'm not going to shut down right now,
I'm going to attack this issue. Now,
the reason that you're getting overwhelmed
most likely is because there's a lot
of different things flying at you at the
same time and they're all happening at
once and it's problematic for you.
We have a very simple solution for that.
It's prioritize and execute.
So what is the biggest problem
that you've got going on?
Let's identify what
that biggest problem is.
Then let's attack that problem and get
it solved. Once we got that one solved,
we can move on to the next one.
Once we get to take care of that one,
we can move on to next. When we
go right on down the line, that's,
that's what we do.
That's very simple.
You know that you're going to
get overwhelmed. First of all,
tell yourself you're not
going to go overwhelmed.
Then you've actually don't
get overwhelmed, and how
do you not get overwhelmed?
You prioritize and execute.
If you start feeling
yourself getting overwhelmed,
do what I did to the platoon commander
that I had that was getting all freaked
out during, during um, the Humvee.
I address immediate action drills where
you're patrolling through the desert and
we have little electrical targets
at pop up and then you are,
everyone starts shooting at the targets
and this guy was locking up and not
making any decisions even
though he used to leader.
And this is the one where I took a magic
marker and I wrote with a sharpie right
in front of his face on the Humvee window.
I said, next time the shooting starts,
here's what I want you would want you
to, number one, relax. Number two,
look around. Number three, make a call.
It's really easy. So step number one,
when you're getting overwhelmed,
relax, relax, breathe.
Take a step back.
Just take a step back.
The red flags start going off in your
head and you're realizing that you're
getting overwhelmed and you're going to
get shut down. No, just take a step back.
Relax.
Okay.
And then prioritize and execute.
Pretty simple call. Yeah.
Yeah, it's good. Simple.
Next question.
Let's do it.
What technique do you use to not
lose your temper with your wife? Oh,
when you know she's wrong and refuses
to budge. Well, this is kind of, uh,
this question is actually moot
because my wife is never wrong.
So, so number one, losing your
temper, losing your temper is
weak. It's actually a week. It's
actually a week to lose your temper.
It actually is a loss control
when you lose your temper. And,
and losing control is also weak.
So we don't, we don't want to lose our
temper. That's, that's one of our goals.
So again,
just like prioritize and execute.
What do you do when you start feeling
yourself losing your temper? Stop.
Take a step back,
detach from it brief.
And then you got to think
about the long term victory.
And we've talked about this before.
We've talked about this before.
Proving that your right to your wife is
not necessarily the best gold to have.
What you want to do is you want to,
you want to win the war.
Not that one battle.
The one battle doesn't even matter.
I mean,
what is this stupid
argument about anyways?
It's not about something that matters.
It isn't.
I can almost guarantee it's not
about something that matters.
It's about some random thing that
doesn't matter in the big picture at all.
So why are you getting upset about it?
Why are you losing control? Why are you
losing your temper? You can't do that.
You can't do that.
So when you feel like you're coming
up against the, this is some zoo,
you know you're going against
a heavily defended position,
don't attack the heavily
defended position.
If your wife is not
admitting that she's wrong,
she's refusing to budge what have you,
what are you doing and
what you're attacking her.
You're actually attacking a
heavily defended position.
Some sue told you not to do that 2,500
years ago and it holds true to this day.
So what are you going to do when they're,
when they're not budging,
you're going to flank up.
You're going to flank them,
your new blue move around to the outside
and come in from another angle that
they weren't expecting.
You know,
maybe that other angle looks like flowers.
Maybe the other angle looks like dinner,
maybe it looks like,
maybe just looks like changing the
subject to something that they can be more
flexible mentally on.
Because
if you,
if you go against that hardened position,
I can almost guarantee
you it's not going to,
they're not going to budge on it in all
your w what you're going to do to try
and get them to budge is you're
going to escalate yourself. Oh,
you're not budging. They hit it
harder. Oh, you're still not budging.
I'm going to go even harder.
You're still not budging and going
to be harder there that whole time.
Every time you're going harder. They're
digging the defenses in deeper, deeper,
deeper,
and they're remembering how,
how mean you are or whatever.
Especially if you're in a,
in a loss of 10 per situation.
Oh yeah. Now you're,
now you're taking serious detriment to
your longterm war because you've now
you've given them ammunition. You've
given them ammunition for future use,
bad move. It's a bad move. Uh, so
again,
what isn't what the F
who's right and who's wrong
is just not important.
It's so hard to get through people's head.
Who's right and who's wrong on some little
tactical babble battle of today that
really has no bearing on
anything in the world.
This is not something to
be concerned about. Yup.
So it might be your own
ego that wants to be right.
Have we thought about that factor? Have
we thought about that? You as a man,
as a husband,
you want to be right too.
So guess who the person that isn't budge,
guess who the person they've done
isn't budging us. It's you. It's you.
Now you might be quote unquote,
right? But it doesn't matter.
You're the person that won't budge.
Now neither one of you will budge.
Neither one are you have budge.
We're not in a good situation.
We're just in an escalating
war of destruction and we
don't want that because we
want to win the long term strategic war.
That's what we're looking at.
Just the longterm strategic wore
the little stuff in between.
We just not concerned about. Yeah. Yeah.
Fully in the whole not budging thing too,
like that hurts a nice
to think about this.
Early on in my relationship
where I would get,
we'd get in little arguments or whatever,
um,
varying levels and
sometimes she would like,
can you even come up with an example
of something you'd argue about?
Because as I was trying to
think as I was sitting here,
as I was answering this question,
I was trying to think of a good exam.
I can't even think of a good example.
Yeah. Because they're all so stupid.
Yeah. So, yeah. A good example.
No, that's hard. Not really. Um,
but so she would be like, oh, I just
don't want to talk about it anymore.
But meanwhile I'm still salty.
Like, Hey, we didn't resolve this.
You know,
there's certain code words,
like a safe word that girls, that women
that guys have it too. But in particular,
I've noticed it with some of my friends'
wives and, um, one of my wife's,
she'll say, doesn't, it doesn't matter.
What do you mean buzzword like a code
note pizza. It's a, it's a red flag.
So I'll give an example.
She, it'll just be a,
it'll be a giant red flag that she's,
that she's angry. She doesn't jog.
Nothing I say is going to matter anymore.
She's not going to change your mind
and she's just going to go forward and
she'll be like, oh, it doesn't matter.
I'm like, oh, okay. We all morning,
Eh big H is angry.
That's what it means.
So when I hear her say it doesn't
matter, I just realized, okay, I'm now,
I just hit it, uh, uh,
heavily defended position and I'm going
to stop attacking it. I'm going to flank,
I'm going to talk about something else.
I'm coming in from the side hatch.
That's what I'm going
to do. Yeah. Yeah Man,
I wish I would've known that long
time ago. I think that when w wait,
what did you just say that
your wife said to you?
Cause you just said a code word. I
mean, uh, I don't want to talk about it.
I don't want, there you go.
That's another one. Yeah.
I want to talk about the sets that too,
that's a red flag in my mind. It was like,
Yay, let's talk about it. I try, I would
try to do it in a conducive way. Like,
you know, like a problem
solving kind of way. But she,
she just didn't feel the same way
about the whole situation. You know,
she handles it different.
And you know,
ultimately I still feel like if two
people are willing to talk it out kind of
without too much emotion, I think
that's, that's an effective way to do it.
But nonetheless,
what this would cause is,
and this is going back
to people not budget,
so what that would cause is all this time
that would go on that were not on good
terms. You know, because
I want to talk about it.
She doesn't want to talk about it. She
just wants to, I don't know, go to bed,
you know. Meanwhile I am
with the philosophy of don't
go to bed in an argument or
whatever, you know, but meanwhile
we're at odds even just a little bit.
Even if we don't talk about it, she
forgets about it. I'm still at odds.
I'm not budging with my philosophy,
you know? So at the end of the day,
when you look back at all the minutes,
all the hours,
all the days that you
spent with each other,
and now you have that, that, that some of,
of moments that you're at odds, you look
in your relationship, you're like, man,
this relationship isn't that good because
he spent that much time at odds with
each other just because you
didn't want to budge. Yes.
So you've got to budge. You
got a buddy, one of my buddies,
I was hanging around with
him and his wife and uh, her,
her little buzzword where I was like,
Ooh, I picked up on it pretty quickly.
She would say, that's fine.
And I was like, and at first,
you know, first couple times I
was like, oh, it's fine with her.
And then I realize it does not mean that's
fine. I think that's kind of common.
A common knowledge one though would
worlds like you can look that up.
I think that's fine. Fine, whatever.
Whatever's offensive though.
Oh yeah. And then they know if
they say whatever then that,
that means that's fighting words.
If you'll notice, that's fine.
And it doesn't matter.
They are all, they're all
like sort of passive way of saying
like, oh, let's just move on.
Yeah. I don't want to talk about it. That
one's a borderline. Yeah. Or it's like,
it's like one of the,
so what's good is when you're,
when you detach from the situation,
she start to pick up on these
things that your significant other.
And also there's, when you're
in a relationship, you're in,
it's team building and Vara team
environment, or you're in a business,
you start to realize that guys or people
you work with will have this same thing
where they'll say, you know
what? It's your call. Okay.
I know it's my call, but I'm not trying
to impose this plan on you. Let's,
let's figure it out. No, it's
your call. We'll go ahead. Yeah.
So that means you clearly
don't agree with it.
Of course you can't say this to them
because they're already dug in on the fact
that you're right.
You know that you're wrong.
So those are little red flags you gotta
look out for in the world. Yeah. So
that's fine. And he didn't that that's
a complex thing because you know,
when someone says, fine,
you know what's wrong,
what's wrong? Nothing,
right? Oh, you know,
or you have reason to
believe that it's not fine,
especially the fine or that's fine.
You have good reason to believe
that it's not fine. Right?
So in your mind it's logical to think,
hey,
you shouldn't say you're
fine when you're not fine.
You actively chose to say you're
fine when you're not fine factually.
So it's easy to come to
that logical conclusion, but
there's your problem, right?
Logical solution. I know. It's
just, it's not that simple.
It's not that black and white.
So,
and I'm saying this because I kind of
up until really recently I thought that,
hey look,
I'm not really wrong with this thing.
I asked you a very specific question.
If you're saying you're fine, it's,
it's like it doesn't even matter what
you say. I have to read like your,
your mind or your,
your body language and everything
you know and disregard your words.
And only under these circumstances,
not when you, when I say, Hey,
do you need, I don't know, milk from
the store. You say, no, I know you mean,
yeah, you know, it doesn't work like
that. It's only under this circumstance.
So it's like, Hey, I'm thinking, Hey man,
that's kind of, that's not very good.
That's, that's a bad thing in habit
to get in. So if you're not fine,
you should say you're not.
That's my logic is what I'm saying.
But here's the thing,
when you're in a relationship with someone
and it start to understand and starts
at the beginning where you're
trying to figure all this stuff out,
that's what the beginning
of the relationship before.
But after a while you start to
know, okay, I know that tone.
I know when you say fine,
it's not,
the thing that's jacked up is when people
don't realize that what that the dead
as a code word, that means
something else. Right, right.
Signifying is you are coming up
against a heavily defended area.
I'm not changing my mind, but I'm not
going to sit here and argue about it. So,
you know what doesn't matter is what my
wife would say. Oh, it doesn't matter.
Man wouldn't matters when, when Sarah
would say, I don't want to argue,
I don't want to argue about this.
It's fine. Let's not talk about it.
That would enrage me for further.
Not like I'm not a lose temper kind of
whatever, but um, we re frustrates you.
It wouldn't make me will be like, no,
we have to go to, it's like, you know,
if you have like fucking like a,
like a splinter,
like if you have a splinter in your
hand or something not talking about it,
it's like I just leave it, let the
skin grow over it and you'll be fine.
And the thing is,
you probably will be fine.
But he's still got that splinter in there.
Me. I'm like, okay, let's talk about,
let's open it up and get the splinter out.
But she's like, no, you know,
ripping that splinter out. Yeah. And
I know that sometimes the, again,
you're going up against a
hardened defensive area and
that's what we're talking
about here. That's what the
question is. The question is,
how do you not lose your temper with your
wife when you know she's wrong and she
refused to budge.
You know how you now you don't do it.
You know how you maintain your temper,
you realize that you're in a,
you're in a strategic situation where
you're just gonna win strategically.
You can to outsmart,
you're going to help maneuver.
You're going to out manipulate, I'm
sorry. You can manipulate the situation.
That's what you're going to do.
And you're going to make her think,
you know what man,
I was kind of a chair class night
to my wonderful husband. Yeah,
yeah. That's what we ought to have. Yeah.
You got to do it in this genuine way.
You know, like you're so you gotta be
genuine, real genuine and open and warm.
No one wants to attack you when
you're in that state, you know?
So that's what you do. Me,
my wife, no rug telling you.
Maybe if you switch all of a sudden
and she's like, hey, this is the trick.
But if you're like, if you put it
on here, just disarming them. Yes,
exactly. You disarm him. But man, it's
hard to do when you lose your temper.
I answered a question the other day.
I was at an event and I answered
her question. I was like, listen,
do not take marriage advice from me
cause the question, it's a long story.
But the question was about, you know,
how do you do your job when you have all
this pressure and how do you maintain
your family? And I kind of went through
the story of like, Hey, you know,
my family came second and that's
really hard for people to understand.
And I went through the whole thing and
I had got to the end and I said, listen,
don't take marriage advice for me.
And everyone kind of laughed. But uh,
but in a situation like this to actually
take marriage advice roommate, yeah.
Don't attack defended positions. I've
said that 47 times right now. Yeah.
And it's not to say that you've
never attacked, defended.
I don't know if you ever
have it with your wife,
but I'm just saying that sounds
like good objective advice.
I probably haven't done that.
And so long it's like it's like one are
we going to ask on the podcast when we
got asked us on the podcast,
when is the last time that you were dug
in on a on a position and how did you
admit that you are wrong?
And I was like, Oh man,
I haven't been dug in on a position
and years. I don't even remember. Yeah,
so it's the same thing here. What do I
attack my wife in a defended position?
Something that she's super crazy and
passionate about and I'm not going near
that thing. Yeah. Yeah. The losing
your temper thing too, and I learned,
and I mentioned this before,
where I'd learned about just getting mad
in general from this book called Mind
Games.
He was teeny tiny little book.
One chapter was not even one page and
get your first review on the podcast.
You can be the reviewer, we can mine.
Some of them were like puzzles, you know,
to see how your mind works anyway,
but it,
what it did was indicate
this as Plinko involved.
That's the price is right.
Anyway,
what it indicated was that losing
your temper or having anger issues,
anger management is was it will,
it was a result of low self esteem.
So those words. Exactly right. And
that's how I always felt when we,
you know in like elementary school,
intermediate school when they talk about
self esteem and whatever and so low
self esteem,
high self,
I'll be like man that's so
embarrassing to have low self esteem.
It was like a almost like a pride thing,
you know where I would even if I really
felt like doing something or whatever, I,
if it indicated overtly that I had a low
self esteem, if I did I wouldn't do it.
It was like really it made you think
that paranoia was caused by a low self
esteem in a way are probably
good. So it's like the, you know,
this would be all switcheroo there.
So now I took that like times to where
it said look everyone gets angry.
It's a natural part of life.
But if you have anger management issues,
it is most likely from as low self esteem.
So I took that as if I ever get angry.
That's a low self esteem.
So Matt and that would be on my mind
every single time where anytime I felt
myself getting mad I'd be like, nope, I
don't have low self esteem. So what that,
did those train me never to lose my
temper. I said if I felt like no,
I think I was always laid
back Paul. But, but anyways,
I think that's kind of a thing
to check though. You know,
we're losing your temper
was like, man, what's up?
What's up with you for shooting your
temporary? Don't lose your temper,
that's for sure.
Hey,
you know that splinter analogy again?
Oh man, Bro, I'm telling you the case.
So this one time, and it wasn't me, it
was jade, he had a splinter where young,
he had a splitter in his hand. We
were like young, young, like five.
I know this because we're living in this
specific house that I remember anyway
to tell us about that. Anyway, he
had a splinter and it was deep. So,
um, my mom was like,
hey, we gotta get it out.
We got to use like a tweezers or
something. It's like no, no, no.
I need to put up this full on. What
do you call it? Like a pardon defense.
We're not getting that splinter
out cause he's crying. He's scared.
You know all this stuff. So my
mom did it all right, you know,
let's don't take out the splitter.
What he did,
what she did was wait
for him to go to sleep.
She knew you just take out the splinter.
It may or may not hurt for like a
second, but it's out. Who Cares?
We waited for him to go
sleep like a little nap.
She goes in there gently and just picks
it up. Boom. Problem solved later.
Basically Mama Charles flanked him, she
flanked him, totally flanked them. Then
props to prompts the moment.
Charles, next question. Yes please.
Good Lord. How do you balance
loyalty to your workmates and USP?
Personal sense of honor with self interest
when it comes to career progression.
So this question is,
is has,
is giving the impression that that being
loyal to your Bros and being loyal to
your workmates and and having pride is
the opposite of of career progression,
which is actually,
I understand that is coming from,
but it's actually does
not have to be true.
That does not have to be the way you
think that the way you get around this as
number one, you work
hard. That's what you do.
You work hard and you do a
good job not for promotion,
not for self interest,
but to help the team accomplish the goal.
That's what you should
be working hard for.
That's what you should be doing
a good job for. And if you're,
and this is something I've said
a bunch of times over the years,
I don't know if I've ever
said on the podcast before,
but I used to tell my
guys because we'd be,
we'd be in some long term administrative,
psychological warfare in
our community, in, in the,
in the seal teams are in our
organization. And I'd say, look,
if we're doing the right
thing for the right reason,
we're going to win in the end. And, and
I totally believe that to be true. Now,
for instance,
I never really cared about
rank or being promoted.
Now that being said,
I actually did put in an officer package
so that I could become an officer.
Now why did I do that?
I didn't do that out of greed
or out of hunger for power.
I did it because I had worked for a prior
enlisted officer and he made our lives
really good cause he was a really good
leader. And I said, you know what?
I'd like to make a bunch of the guys that
I know make 16 guys in a seal platoon
make their lives better.
Maybe I can do that. So that,
that's sort of what led me to do it.
I didn't do it out of
out of self interest in greed.
I did it to help my bros right now.
Then once I got promoted,
I, once I became an officer,
then I just busted my ass to do
the best job I could. And again,
I was never concerned with being promoted.
But in order to do a good job,
guess what I did?
I built relationships.
I took some hard jobs,
I followed the rules,
I supported the chain of command.
I told the Party line,
why did I do those things?
It wasn't because I was
trying to get promoted,
it's cause I was trying to do a good job.
And the more relationships I had and
the more respect I had from the chain of
command, the more power I had to help
my guys. It wasn't about power for me.
It was about power for the good of the
platoon so I could accomplish it. And,
and I knew that.
I believed in the broad
mission that we were doing.
I knew that good order and discipline
actually makes troops perform better.
I knew that and I knew that
by following the rules,
by supporting the chain of command,
I knew that towing the part,
I knew that those things would
build trust in the chain of command.
And I knew that building trust and
the chain of command and being viewed
positively from up the chain of command
meant that I would get more support from
the chain of command,
which once again would make it easier
for my guys to do their job because I
could get a more gear, I could get
them the assets that they needed.
I could actually legitimately protest
if something came down the pipe that I
didn't agree with.
If I didn't have trust in bill,
had built a relationship
with my senior, uh, officers,
how can I go back to him and say, Hey,
I don't think we should be doing this.
They don't know me.
They don't trust me.
But when you build that trust and
you could have a more open and honest
conversations,
which again is only done so that
my platoon can have an easier life.
So that they can do their job better
because I believed in the mission.
So everything that I was doing that I was
doing to make my platoon have a better
go at things,
make my platoon more efficient,
make my platoon more
effective on the battlefield,
all those things that I was doing,
I was doing to make that.
And Lo and behold, when you're doing those
things, when you're busting your ass,
when you're trying to make
life good for your platoon,
would so that your platoon
can more effectively and
efficiently accomplished its
mission on the battlefield?
Well guess what?
Those are aligned with a guy that's
working hard and to supporting chain of
command.
So I would get ranked number one why not?
Because I was trying to get promoted,
not for self interest.
It's because I was trying to
do a good job for my boys.
So the bottom line is if you care about
doing a good job and the the and you're
doing things that will
help you do a good job.
Again, not for promotion and not for
recognition, but to truly do a good job.
The end result is most
likely gonna be positive.
Now the caveat to this is does that mean
that you'll be the first person to get
promoted?
No.
Does it mean that you are
guaranteed to get promoted? No.
Some other guy that brown nose and took
all the credit he didn't deserve and
stepped on a people as
backs to get to the top.
He's probably going to get promoted ahead
of you and he probably is. It's okay.
It's okay. I will tell you that that
will come back to haunt him eventually.
Maybe not this year,
maybe not next year,
maybe in five years people are going
to see through that eventually and you
who's doing the right things for the
right reasons you will win in the end.
Yeah.
When we talked about this a lot where
if you're doing it just to get the
promotion, they're going to see that
man, I get to smell it. That guy.
Yeah and not only
is the basket,
everyone's going to smell it on you.
I talked about that earlier tonight,
cause if you were going to, if you like,
if you volunteer to be
the admiral's aid yeah.
Then then that was a total red
flag. Watch out for this guy. Yeah,
I see what you're doing. Yeah.
You don't want to be that guy.
You want to be doing the right things
for the right reasons. Yeah. And that is,
that is how in the long run you will get
the recognition and the promotions and
the credit that you deserve.
Because why wouldn't you? Yeah.
You're busting your ass to do a great job.
You're gonna get,
you're gonna shine eventually gammon.
And if you're focused on doing the
best job you can do. That's the bit,
that's really the,
the dynamics of promotions anyway.
It or it should be ideally shouldn't.
For me it was definitely over time it
will be because there is somebody that
Brown noses. The boss. Yeah.
That maneuvers to take these little
missions or to do things to get the
recognition that he's there. There's
a guy that's doing that, you know,
and they can't get promoted and you
gotta accept that and not succumb to it,
not submit to it. Cause you don't
want to be that guy in the long run.
The guy that busts his ass that takes
cares of his troops that towed the party
line that does the right things for the
right reasons is going to win in the end.
You got to believe in that. And then you
know, guys do that in Jujitsu, right?
Sometimes the,
we talked about that too where they have,
they do they have the wrong mindset.
They just want that purple belt,
Brown belt or whatever. Yeah.
They want the next belt. Um,
or I want to tap that guy or I
want to tap this. Right. Yeah.
Those are the wrong reasons. Yeah.
Folks that, yeah. If the guys who,
who are just in it to be
the best that they can be.
You see them asking questions or
going over some stuff, you know,
on their own kind of thing where they,
they just want to learn as much as they
can and get good at as much as they can.
And in the long run, those are going
to be the, the guys that shine. Yeah.
And men. And I think that, I think that's,
it's such a huge deal and it goes for
Jujitsu or even that at work or whatever.
And if you're the guy who they can see
what you're doing and you're kissing ass
or, or like the guy. Okay.
This is one of the most embarrassing
things you can do in my opinion,
in Jujitsu is after a promotion you didn't
get promoted and then you're overtly
unhappy about it and don't go one
step further and say something about,
Oh, I tapped that guy all the time and
he got his belt. Ooh, don't ever do it.
Don't do it. Don't tell
you, don't do it. Yeah. That
doesn't, that doesn't bode well.
I don't think you could ever really
live that down. It's just unnecessary.
It just shows, hey guys, look at
me. I'm focused on the wrong thing.
I'm focused on like wearing a belt
rather than my skill. You know?
I'd rather get a belt and
maybe not have the skill.
I'd rather that then had the skill
and maybe not have the belt right now.
That's what you're saying. Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If it is that any good Jujitsu guy would
rather have the skill and not have the
belt right now, by the way, you
don't have the belt right now.
If you have the skill, you'll get the
belts, you know, that's just part of the,
you don't want, it could be a long time.
Yeah. And you know what? That's okay. Oh,
unless you quit, then you won't have, oh,
you know, then you won't have the belt.
But that's where you got to also accept
the fact that some guy's going to get
promoted to head of you. Good. Good thing
you good? You tapped them before. Good,
good. That's perfect. Keep that up.
Yeah, we going to get you that belt.
Stop whining.
I heard of a guy who left the gym,
our gym because he didn't get a belt.
And you have a site called,
I'm just gonna go somewhere
else. Yeah, that's too bad.
I just heard it was a story. I
wasn't there enough anywhere.
Next question, unless we have more
on that one. No, we're good. Good.
Dead horse has been beaten.
Yeah, don't be that guy, man.
Jocko on team building.
When leading a team,
do you feel that there's any benefit
to team building exercises or retreats?
Well,
this is a interesting question
that actually I feel that
fairly qualified to answer because we,
we Lafe and I,
we have a little business called
echelon front where that's a,
we work with a lot of different
companies on a different,
a wide range of different categories.
Sometimes we go in and work with
a business. Sometimes we go on,
we'll do a keynote speech for a business,
like there'll be having a big meeting
and we'll go in and do one keynote speech
for an hour and we leave and we're done.
But most of the time we're doing more
long range stuff where we spend time with
the company we go in.
But oftentimes we do do some kind of
situation where their company has decided
to do some kind of a leadership offsite
or a team building exercise or a
leadership retreat. And we, we mostly
get involved with the leadership,
although that does sometimes
trickle down to where we're,
we'll do some work with all
the frontline troops. Um,
so we constantly see these,
these leadership off sites and
we speak and, or lead them.
Sometimes we run the whole thing.
And there are definitely some outstanding
events and we'd been participated in
and led some outstanding events
with, with companies. And I think
one of the most important things
about these offsites is it,
it forces the leadership team to detach
from the day to day firefights of what
the business has.
No matter what the there,
there's no businesses where the CEO and
the c suite or like sitting around not
doing anything, they, those,
those companies don't exist.
That at least that I've seen those,
you know, you're trying to expand,
you're trying to grow, you've got com
competitors making moves. So you're,
you're in the fight and then you've
got operational things are happening.
So you're in the fight. So when you
do these leadership offsites there,
it's good that you get them to focus on
some other development in some whatever
issues they're having in areas
where they can improve. So there,
it gives them the opportunity to focus
on those things and also gives them the
opportunity to self assess as a team
how they're doing and themselves as
leaders,
how they're doing.
And when I talked to
people about leadership and
teamwork and the short falls
and the pitfalls that exist, and then
when I, when they hear me talk about it,
they recognize their own weaknesses.
I, every time I get done they go, man,
when you were talking about,
you know when you were talking about ego,
sometimes I think I let my ego get in
the way or that when you were talking
about covering movement,
I don't think I'd,
well when you're talking about ownership,
they,
they see areas of their own weaknesses
and they see where they can improve and
then when you get the whole team that's
all learning that same information,
they're all doing that same
self assessment and then
the whole leadership team
gets aligned to behind the same leadership
principles of ownership and humility
and cover and move and
simple decentralized command.
And all of those things that I talk
about that is extremely powerful.
It is extremely powerful
and we see really drastic turnarounds
with the companies that we work with and
has awesome. It's awesome
to see. And then one,
one thing that we do when we work
more in depth with a company,
we do our own leadership off sites
where we do simulated combat.
And I know it sounds it. It sounds if,
if I wouldn't have done it so many times,
I would be surprised that it's, it's
possible, but we take either paint guns,
paintball guns or air soft guns and we
teach them the basic shooting principals
and we teach them some basic small
unit tactics and then we go and perform
mission. We have them perform missions
and every time they got eight guys,
they got 10 guys, they got 12 guys, girls,
whatever in their group and
they go and assault a target.
They come up with a plan,
they go out,
we put one person in charge and that
person has to lead a mission and they,
what they theorized
in the classroom,
they now get to put to the test and they
learn those lessons very, very clearly.
You know,
we,
we'd see a guy that would be a really
strong leader and he was like, okay,
I'm the, I'm in charge of this
run. Here's what I'm going to do.
Here's the way the plants could go down.
You're going to do this,
you're going to this,
you're going to this.
You see that micromanagement start and
then as soon as they start the operation,
everyone is expecting to get micromanaged.
So no one's thinking on their own.
So now you get a decentralize,
a lack of decentralized
command and everything goes
sideways and nobody does and
he thinks it all being
waiting to be told what to do.
So that's an example of the kinds
of things that people learn. Um,
so with all that, yes,
absolutely. We, you know,
I've been to,
and we run some,
some pretty awesome dean building
exercises and retreats and leadership off
sites that are, that are great and
we've seen awesome results from a wall.
I've also sat through some off sites
that are, that are not that effective.
Um,
you know,
you get situations where people don't
open up or there's no exchange or you get
these team building exercises that,
that some people set up and there's some
kind of physical or mental challenge.
And while they might be hard and they
might take some teamwork to perform,
they don't break the paradigm
that the company is in.
So they'll end up leading through
that challenge or whatever it is.
Whether it's a,
some kind of a PT,
some kind of physical training or some
kind of a boat race or something like
that. They'll lead through that
challenge. The way they always lead,
the way they currently lead.
So nothing is learned and nothing is
gained and no leadership advancement has
been made and all they've done is
actually all they've actually done is
reinforce the bad leadership
situation that they already have.
So that's,
that's one of the things that I've seen
that can be problematic and that's why
we've gone to the direction that we
go, where we really focus on, let's do,
let's look at leadership and
the team working together,
how, what the leadership dynamics are,
what our weaknesses are, what we see,
where we uncover the friction, where we
see the team not working well together.
Where we see the leaders
not stepping up and leading,
where we see the leaders
egos get in the way. I mean,
there's so many things that we uncover
and find. It's, it's phenomenal. And it,
and it really does make it fun for us,
you know,
because every time you see a
new leadership team, you, it's,
it's like diagnosing a patient and you,
you look at the problems that they're
having. They say, oh, well, you know what,
try this over here. Take this off a
little bit. And the next thing you know,
you've got that patient up and
running and they're winning.
Or like a mechanic when he grabs the
car. Right? Yeah. You know, uh, yeah,
some of those leadership, or not
leadership necessarily, but these,
these teen building retreats too,
sometimes it seems like whoever organized
them really wasn't focusing on results.
They're just focusing on our
annual, uh, you know, retreat.
So they make it in like The Bahamas
and all these, um, you know,
these activities are like kind of fun,
you know?
Then every once in a while I've been in
Administrative Ping or something. Yeah.
And Fun can be part of it. You know,
there's, there's bonding that happens,
there's getting to know each other
and that's always positive. Um,
but the, if you're, I'm all about
having fun. I'm all about bonding,
but I'm even more about learning
even more about improving the guy,
the people
we work with,
the guys and girls that we work with.
I want them to be better leaders.
Right? That's what I want. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
And so I, yeah, sure.
Do I want them to get some team
challenges? Yes. But like I said,
I don't want that to just reinforce the
paradigm that they're already in the
leadership paradigm with authority in.
I want them to improve.
So let's actually break down and look and,
and analyze and diagnose what the
issues are and then let's solve them.
And you know, it's not, it's not always,
it's not always that these teams
go in and there we, you know,
we don't get hired by companies
that are failing. In fact,
most of the time we get hired by
companies that are doing well,
that want to do better. So when I say we
diagnose, diagnose what the problem is,
it's not,
it's,
it's not a problem where it's
causing the company to failure,
but it's a friction point where it is
holding the company back from really
reaching the Beck's best next level and
going from being a really good company
or even an outstanding company to
the best in class company. Gotcha.
So it's like a, it's like a
multivitamin, not a painkiller. Yes.
No, that's not mine. Other than
I read that somewhere. You know,
the micromanaging thing,
it's funny because you're the first
person that I've heard say that this were
where you said they'll start micromanaging
and then all of a sudden the people
getting micro-melt managed expect to
get micromanage. So they stop thinking.
Right. So in a percent, so yeah, and
that happens. It goes the other way too.
If you come to me and you say, Hey
Jocko, how do you want me to do this?
And I go figure it out. And you say, Hey
boss, can you show me how to do this?
And I say, figure it out.
When we get in the field,
you're going to know that I expect you
to figure it out, right? Yeah, man.
Like when I,
when I drive with my life,
she'll start micromanaging like how
I drive, like get in this lane or,
or um, you know, just you're
going too slow or too fast,
too fast, whatever to slow, typically
cold blooded. But here's the thing,
I'm not going to lose my temper, you know,
I don't think front seat in her case,
but yeah, man, for sure. And I'm not
gonna lose my temper. It'd be like, okay.
But that's what I do. I shut
down my brain. And then,
so one time David was riding with us
and he was, uh, like it was actually,
I was micromanaging jade and
he put it in these good terms,
which I thought were good. He said
either be the navigator hundred percent,
cause he stopped thinking, you
know, or don't be it at all.
You can't just start chiming in when
you think I'm going too slow, you know?
Otherwise, yeah. I don't want them.
If Sarah is yelling at me, hey,
you're going too slow, I'm going to be
like, okay, how fast do you want me to go?
I'll go that fast.
So if you're navigating the on the map,
you're going to have to tell me
every turn to make. Don't say, Hey,
you're going to make this right. And then
I make the right thing. You sign off,
you know, cause you're, you're
anticipating the micromanager.
Exactly. Right, man.
And I think it kind of goes automatically.
You know,
you got to put in a lot of materials
where you knew that Sarah never said
anything to you when you got in the car.
All me,
you'd know that you had to have the route
prepped before you got in the vehicle.
Yet we might go a little bit too slow.
But Stillman,
W it's all me as far as thinking
goes, yeah man, don't micromanage.
Or when you micromanage,
don't expect them to just all of
a sudden start making, you know,
creative decisions. It's just hard. It's
hard. It's hard for it to work that way.
Amen. All right, next
question. This is the last one.
Jacko.
Could you tell us any possible regrets
or things you'd done differently?
Something you'd wished
you'd learned sooner.
Regrets.
Things I could've done differently.
Things I wish I learned sooner.
Okay.
Of course there are things
I wish I learned sooner.
There's,
there's so much knowledge out there,
so much information,
so many ways to get better.
Okay?
And we make,
we make so many mistakes.
What are the,
we're the product of our mistakes and
oftentimes the lesson is sitting there
right in front of our face.
It's there to be learned,
but we miss it or we don't pay attention
to it or we think we know better
until it punches
in the face.
In. The most important thing to learn
is that we have so much to learn.
We all do.
And we can learn from school and from
people and from experience and we learned
from life.
But you have to process the information.
You have to absorb it.
You have to except it,
you have to open your mind.
You got to free your mind so that
you can learn and make real progress.
Okay.
In this far as regrets and things
I wish I would've done differently.
Of course,
hindsight,
hindsight is 2020 and looking back,
of course,
who wouldn't want to take another go at
something and improve on the first try
by doing it.
Okay.
And then why not do it
again and again and again.
And why not just do it over and over
again until you have it perfect.
But the fact is you don't get that chance.
Yeah.
You get one shot,
one shot at this gig right here.
Good life.
Yeah.
One life.
That's all you've got.
Okay.
And regret in and of itself.
It's worthless. It does
nothing for you. In fact,
the only valuable thing and
regret is the lesson you learned,
the knowledge that you gained,
but walking around filled
with regret gets you nothing.
So learn and move on.
Don't let regret beat you down.
Don't be a slave to regret.
No.
Let it teach you.
Let it make you better.
Let the fear of regret fueled
you to take action the day now.
Okay.
To take action now to
become a better person.
Not filled with regret.
Okay.
But filled with knowledge,
filled with knowledge,
had strength and power and filled with
yeah,
life.
Yeah,
and I think that's all
I've got for tonight.
No regrets.
Only knowledge and that's what we are
striving for on this podcast to gain
knowledge so we can improve
ourselves and live better lives.
Echo,
can you just go ahead and drop some
knowledge on us right now about how we can
support this podcast. She Ha and or
improve your life. Have a better life.
One ways to supplement your
workouts and your brain with on it.
Supplements Alpha brain.
Shroom tech is a good one for your bars.
Krill oil. Krill oil.
Join right there. Yeah,
it's a big one on it.com/jocko.
Get 10% off. Boom.
Improve your budget as well.
Um,
and if you want to support the podcast
before shopping on amazon.com before you
do that shopping,
go to Jocko podcast.com or [inaudible]
dot com click on the Amazon link.
That's pretty cool. Yes,
you're buying it anyways.
I know you love Amazon because I love
Amazon because it is a squared away system
that delivers things to
your home in hours or days.
And all you gotta do if you want to
help us out is you just got to go there,
go to site, just go to our site
first, click on it, and then boom,
they're not taking more money from you.
They're taking their money and giving it,
they're taking their money and giving
it to support the Jocko podcast,
which is pretty impressive. So
that's much appreciated. Yeah.
So if you're buying some duck
tape or something, the key,
the challenge is remembering to go
right Jocko podcast.com but man,
why you always say duck tape?
Do you get a lot of duct tape from Amazon?
I've gotten, yeah, I always say if
you need duct tape, man, go to Amazon.
I said it once and it kind of stuck.
Duck tailed it anyway that I slept with
guy actually still watch one guy wrote
all the time. That was his thing, man.
Duct tape don't go anywhere without it.
In the military we call it rigorous tape.
Yeah.
And some people call it
120 mile an hour tape,
but I've never called it that one time.
Yeah, but we call the rigors tape. Yeah,
yeah. I got some black
rigorous data. Nonetheless,
if you're getting some or anything
on amazon.com and just try,
if you can just remember to go to Jocko
podcast.com first click on the Amazon
Lincoln booms, automatic supporting
podcasts and we thank you for that.
I thank you for that chocolate things.
And um,
while you're at Jocko store,
if you like any of the shirts,
go ahead,
grab one or a coffee mug or a sticker.
That's a good way to support this
shirt that you're wearing tonight.
It's a little bit new, isn't
it? It's a little new. Yes.
The newest one looks right here.
If you're watching on youtube,
if you're not watching on youtube,
the front of the shirt,
it's a black on black shirt and
black on the front it says no,
the darkness, you'll actually,
ironically, if you're watching on youtube,
you might not even be able to see
no. The darkness. And let's say,
and I mentioned this before,
this, when we made this one,
there's that added layer where it's dark,
the shirt is for you.
It's not to show everyone who look at me,
look at my cool shirt.
The shirt is for you.
You know it's there.
Ain't know my back has got some madness,
some dark, dark, dark, dark picture.
Yup. So easy you do the
shirts, right? I mean,
so this must, what did that like we've
talked about a lot of stuff. Why,
why did you, why did you go
with the darkness? Why did you,
why was that important you that was the
main theme. Remember? Like when you,
when you started or what? Well, okay.
When Jocko started the main theme and
still is the main theme where he goes into
all these dark books and,
and concepts.
And then every time,
like even Tim Kennedy,
when we asked him or one of the questions
was like, hey, how do you, you know,
reconcile,
you know,
being happy or anything that when you've
seen so much darkness and it actually
intensifies your happiness because
you can recognize the good stuff.
So no,
the darkness so you can see the light.
That's kind of the, the
phrase there, right.
So you can appreciate good things way
more when you know bad things and that
goes for everything really.
So you didn't make a
shirt that said be happy,
the light is with us because
you could have made that,
I guess kind of inconsistent though
with the whole feel of thing.
And the bottom line is if you're
surrounded by all the happiness,
it starts to fade. Right?
Right. Yeah, man. Yeah, exactly.
Let's not make a happy shirt.
Let's make a dark shirt. Yeah.
Maybe it's your sick
happy shirt in the future.
But I'm saying for right now
that's where you were feeling.
That's what his feelings. Yeah,
I thought it was appropriate.
I thought it was good. I think
it came out good man. I dig it.
There you go. Or if you like any of the
other ones, discipline equals freedom.
That was a cool one too, I think. Yeah.
Or the one with your head on it anyway
that you can see on whatever 11 I still
haven't seen alive, alive
one in the wild. Like,
I haven't seen travel. I travel all the
time. I haven't seen it at trooper yet.
Just just representing person.
No,
I'm here. I never, I
never have taken a Selfie,
but I think I might do a selfie if I,
if I,
if I see a person in the wild good trooper
out there just represent and hardcore
in an airport somewhere coming straight
up, we can do some burpees and then
you kind of, yeah, I seen
him here. Yeah. In San Diego.
But those are our people.
We know everybody. Yeah.
But I've seen one where I didn't know,
you know, like I didn't know that,
you know, that. Um, like does that
person know I knew him. I know him count,
but I didn't know like
he got a shirt and stuff.
I want to be in Indianapolis or I want
to be in Philadelphia and be walking down
the street and see some guide is a
represent and hardcore in the street.
That'd be awesome.
Well,
I can attest that with the online stuff
I've seen the people representing,
they are representing hardcore.
Yeah. Uh, anything else?
Nope. That's it. If you, if you like it,
just grab one if you want. Right on. Well,
as always,
if you want to continue
this conversation with us,
all these questions we answered
tonight now from guys there, from the
troopers there from you all.
So thank you for doing that.
We are on the interwebs on Twitter.
Echo Charles is at echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
We're also on the Facebook and Instagram.
If you care,
that's where we are and we're
trying to get better. Hey,
you can join us there as
we seek knowledge together
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.